I like how everyone with everyone
without a real job is having funny zoom
conferences yeah Twitter that everyone
with a real job is like suffering and
mine is is the most scary period of
their life right now mm-hmm
it's not [ __ ] fair people like you
know I don't know just [ __ ] like
social media marketing jobs so you're
having like fun sending funny gifts on
yak all day long oh you're so fun it
like taking screenshots of their zoom
conferences and putting them on Twitter
where someone's got a funny hat on it
people that work in restaurants are like
what the [ __ ] yeah yeah people if you're
a person job of need listening to this
podcast we wish you will and you will
get through it and it may be very hard
but you will get through it yeah we
we're we're here to make you giggle that
said these [ __ ] yeah these zoom
conference [ __ ] you if you've ever
worked and like a [ __ ] startup or
like you know this person there's a
whole er personality just like what do
you do you know I mean what do you mean
you like this person who posts the zoom
coffee yeah yeah okay yeah there's
someone I'm thing you know specifically
at fullscreen I will not name it yeah
[ __ ] yeah you boring ass if we're gonna
do [ __ ] thumb [ __ ] finally I could
say what the [ __ ] do you do
stupid ass [ __ ] [ __ ] you man
there's one person I'm thinking of in
particular they always drove me insane
because they always had a big-ass
opinion and about [ __ ]
and but they never did that job and then
they always wanted to call shots and be
very opinionated and all I could think
was you just [ __ ] hire someone else
to write tweets yeah you do here I don't
know what you do here just roll out team
All Hands is quirky this morning
yeah jared is wearing a lion suit
Michaela what do you do what do you do
here you imagine those
people just getting on the zoom
conference and then they think it's like
the standard meeting and it's just this
is the president of the company oh it
was like they just don't have any shirt
on
oh oh hi Kayla hi they have like
isolation written on her chest like it's
a joke this is a [ __ ] dude named Zach
yeah Oh mr. Cheeseman Isaac he's the
president of pepper jack cheese
corporation hi Zachary I just wanted to
sit in on the call today and see what
we're doing I uh yeah yeah I was just um
while I was just actually gonna put a
shirt on and start yeah yeah so and once
they were shirt on what did yeah well
double talk yeah put a shirt on have a
go yeah so I was just gonna line up the
Twitter today I was gonna get the
Twitter online so a lot of cheese tweets
going out today yeah and and you in and
you know here's the thing Zach because a
lot of us are sitting at home now and
you know the sorry I have to fart
extension on Zoom Conference sorry let
me just low sorry let me just disable
well that's table that I don't wear it
wears that's how you get it off I'm
sorry mr. Cheeseman okay yeah there's
this a cutting the cheese joke Zachary
yes I'm just cutting is it is this is
that what this is yes are you sure could
be are you sure if you think it's funny
here's the thing Zach we a lot of us are
sitting at home and in this time you
know I've had really had time to assess
to come sorry it's still on to assess
the company I just need to know Zachary
what the [ __ ] do you do here I say all
the isolation and lipstick on your chest
this dude's got a plastic bag over his
head who's in quarantine look at me I'm
in quarantine
doesn't matter I bought 700 bags ziplock
bags no one else can have them I got him
oh my god wait did imagine having a
serious conversation with your boss over
like zoom or whatever and you have the
fart you're the fart prank expansion off
but I don't even know that exists but it
definitely should just adds fart sounds
to your so note you don't know which one
who did it though guys
hi I'm sorry what was that we have to
talk about your performance recently in
the last part in the last quarter
you haven't been really meeting my
expectations yeah did you just fart I
wasn't me certainly wasn't me I thought
it was it wasn't no definitely not me
okay maybe it was just something weird
with the yeah my fridge or something
yeah cool anyways you haven't what's
that bro
like really like this is a serious
meeting and you're just gonna he's gonna
be like ooh it's not me well it's not me
it's certainly not me well who is it
then it you have a dog or something in
the room no but you're you're old okay
it's coming out of your old ass stomach
I'm not that old
anyways that brings me to my next point
I don't think you're right for this
couple Rob Oh stinky dude it's like
actually coming through my camera smelly
you're gonna fire me while you're
stinking up the joint yeah that was
disrespectful how about [ __ ] HR this
guy's [ __ ] on camera dude don't
contact HR weed that's not necessary at
all fat dumped on camera why would are
you doing this from the toilet how'd you
like a raise
how's that sound yeah that sounds really
good dude actually I'm glad we could
have this conversation
are you actually farting yeah
Ray's sick oh it was you
you